welcome to this video I'm playing climb
512 from Thailand yeah I want to
experiment a bit with them eh it'll
variation here probably we get the Kings
Indian fianchetto now d 5 is hard too
hard to play ok again the panel
variation and I have played this bit 95
recently I've got a got a pretty good
position 95 here I think I take it
Bishop takes I just looks totally weird
it's running right into this pin only
with 95 if he has some yes anyway I take
it him so Bishop takes Bishop h6 young
with the tempo and then d5 and this just
winning something they exchange on now
this is getting getting some material
and these two pieces for the rook yeah
should be six was a very strange loop
runs right into into this problem
if it takes on a one with the bishop
queen a 1 i'm directly threatening queen
g7 checkmate i'm also not not very
convenient ya know it's a bit late
yeah maybe you can take a one plan play
of six and that's very ugly but what are
you going to do instead of it okay i'm
giving up the piece like that Brooksie
one or 94 cure 94-96 also quite good and
maybe do this now Matt c6 is a big fork
or 27 Bishop c6 not helping just take c6
next
I'm taking one is seven on you know I
guess so ok now i can just go back if I
want all playbook see one there's
nothing wrong with that ok I can take
and then my bishop would hang are not
not so not such a good idea pilling ok
better return with the piece and get it
back to f3 or something
yo I guess just back this wasn't doing
much anymore on on age 6 yeah the fun
thing is they they take like nose time
to get the lost position but after that
day with a piece down for nothing I
start to go into into the think tank
check we are getting the Queen's off
would help and if he takes I have their
file I mean shouldn't be too bad to get
the F file opened check we are here
Knight f3 wins wins another exchange on
b6
okay how to there's some way to to to
win quickly am maybe not maybe I can
play AG for g5 trying to to get at f 7
am-10 age form Jim I don't know if it's
necessary to do something complicated
maybe here threatening H form
and it takes 35 um yeah gets the Queen's
off on or Quincy had another piece check
and now I'm winning winning another
piece check my Queen f7 also wasn't bad
but okay black resigns yeah this was
Bishop me six was was a really weird
decision isn't this like it's winning
straightaway right you know check just
this in Bishop 86 he can only try to
fight here with with with an exchange
down maybe this is the relatively best
way to do I give up give up this and try
to to do something with the dark squared
bishop but in essence is just an
exchange the way it was played d5 is
winning a piece for no particular
compensation yeah very very easy win
after 95 I think they mostly play e6 but
there are even those kind of moves
possible quite quite funny the basic
idea of 95 is that if black takes this
is opening up the C file for white which
is quite nice and quite often the knight
on c3 can get attacked by b5 before and
getting rid of it is often quite a good
idea and you sometimes win-win time and
if you look at this for example this is
winning some time for wide so that you
can get in rook c1 and do something on
the sea fowl if plug insists on b5 so
this is nothing special this 95 line but
it's a it's a playable option that
avoids some some mainline no theory
alright thanks for watching